Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 18, 2017 what's going on how are you?
how's it going everybody? How are you starting a new week? Get out there.
Put your pants on one leg at a time, Joe. Six pack going to work.
Um, I got to keep it down. This is new. This, this is the new, uh, more subdued,
quieter podcasts. Now that I have a baby daughter,
um, I'm recording this Sunday night and uh,
that's all you need to fucking know Mike fucking are you hearing that? My,
you're in some sort of weird noise there. I don't know what I did.
My fucking mixer is acting weird. What happens if I push this button? Anything?
Anything? Oh, there you go.
Just goes into one speaker and then the other one had fallen than the other.
How are you? Did you enjoy your football Sunday? Did you Julius sports weekend.
Did you follow politics? Did you watch college football?
You just stare at the wall. Drinking boobs, ignoring your loved ones will,
if you did, I'm jealous.
Billy. No booze. Billy, what? Where? Oh,
tell me where'd your booze go? Billy boy. Billy boy.
Tell me where did your Booz go? Charming. Billy.
It's sitting over there and every night a fucking steer but I can't have a
fucking drop because I got active work. Yes,
I kid have a fucking drop cause I got acting work.
See I'm slowly losing my mind. What if I just said one bill?
[inaudible] [inaudible] what if you just had one charming Billy?
Well then I drink the whole bottle and I taught computer on the couch and I be a
fat fuck on camera and HD.
I'm down to one 76 and change and he'd been working out because I was playing
catch and fucked up my fucking calf. That's how old I am.
So I've just spent eating like an angel, you know,
after every bite I count and I chew fucking 27 times on each side of my mouth
and then I take the Napkin and I wipe off like a fucking angel.
If there is a God, Allah,
whatever the fucking peanut butter sandwiches you read to or that are la peanut
butter sandwiches. I wonder if fucking, uh,
the couch getting any death threats from extreme Muslims?
Well, maybe he was Muslim. I don't know.
They never really said God knows sesame street was liberal enough.
They probably would have thrown that in back then. Right.
And then Bob would be fucking singing that song. A, what is it?
Who are the people in your neighborhood, in your name?
[inaudible] Oh, who are the people in your neighborhood?
The people that you meet each day. Oh, uh,
fucking puppet vampire. That app is be Muslim is in your neighborhood.
Just too long. That's what it was. Yeah, it's too fucking long. Um,
you have an add, Devin, add a drop of booze in fucking 32 days.
32 fucking God damn days. I'll die right now. I'm not going gonna lie to you.
This was the longest month in a day of the year. Without a doubt.
Um, it's fun in the morning. It's not in the evening. Like right now.
I just want to get fucking blasted, you know, I dunno.
Can't do it though. Can't do it.
Gradually calm it down and got to get down to a buck 72 my fighting weight is
Bob. Pogo says onF is for family season too. While you're watching,
are you liking how you're giving it a thumbs up,
whatever the fucking scoring system is over there at Netflix, you know,
I don't know what they use and now they think they said they were gonna go with
thumbs up, thumbs down. And I think they stuck with the star system.
I have no idea. I don't pretend to know. Um,
I whole fucking weekend, it's just been about keeping my fucking leg raised.
I went to this fucking party on Thursday night with my lovely wife and the
fucking host of it was given a big speech and I was stone sober and I had to go
over and sit in the corner was outside in this guy's lawn with like a tent.
Right. And I'm sitting,
I go off in the corner to sit down and stone sober with a fucking,
I had like club soda in line.
The hardest thing for me to order,
cause I can never remember what you're saying. I could just for seminar,
I can never remember club soda cause I never order it.
And half the time I go up to the bartender of the bay, what can I get you?
I'm like, yeah,
what's that thing people drink when they don't drink and then they go club soda.
I go yes with a line.
I'm not even trying to be funny like a third of the time.
That's how I have to order it because I can't remember what it is cause I never
ordered.
So I'm on my second club soda and lime in this guy who's hosting the party.
Fabulous whole these fucking tank and all these people.
I had to go outside the tent cause I see a stone wall where I can sit down
because my fucking ankle is filling up with fluid.
Um, and it's becoming twice the size of my other ankle. But you know,
I went to the, you know,
I just went into some walk in clinic and the guy looked at it going,
I'll tell you what, I'll tell you. I can tell you what you did right now.
I can tell you from across the fucking room without even doing an x ray,
you know, walk in clinic type Shit, you know.
So I go to sit down the guys in the middle of this great speech,
everybody's fucking listening and I don't know how,
but I set my glass down and I reached back to get something.
I knocked it off and it made that and it was like a fucking wineglass so it
sounded like a booze glass in the middle of his speech and like half the tent
fucking looks over at me. I spilled it on my leg, I did all of this stone sober.
So my half comes walking out. She's laughing at me going, what did you do?
And I was all embarrassed gone.
I was going near stomach and a scene like I felt bad enough as it was.
And then she got mad at me cause I got like, I got, you know,
I got emotional with her so she didn't,
didn't talk to me for like two fucking days because of that two fucking days she
started talking to me. You know what I mean?
Like if she ever spilled a drink in herself and half a tent to people looked
over at her and I walked over and said like, what did you do? You know,
mad she'd be at me. But that's how it works in the male female dynamic.
All right.
You're either wrong or you were too mean when you were right.
That's basically how it was. That's what it was.
I think I was guilty of being too mean. So anyways, I, um,
I watched a little bit of the Patriots today. I saw the first quarter,
I taped the game. I'm going to watch the rest of it. Uh,
patriots with a little bit better today. Obviously it's early in the season,
you know, this is what they always do.
They hype up shit because people are winning.
Beating teams are losing to teams and all this shit that you're not going to see
in January. Who gives a fuck, right. That's just getting going. And um,
I actually went to a,
I went to the stubhub Senate today and I saw the new Los Angeles charges their
first game against the Miami Dolphins. Um,
I went down there, I gotta tell you that might be the best stadium.
I've seen a football game and at the NFL level simply because there was only
25,000 people there.
I can't believe the patriots are playing the charges on the road.
If I could see Tom Brady and a 25,000 seat stadium of that be fucking
incredible. That's like old. That's like what the old NFL used to look like
back before, you know,
we out fucked all of those other stadiums back before lady Gaga and fuck it,
Whitney Houston, everybody brought all these other people into the game.
All these people who are just like, oh my God,
what else happens after the concert? You know,
when they started watching football, so they had to build 50, 60, 70, 80,
a hundred thousand fucking seat stadiums.
25,000 seat seats. I got to see two wily veterans,
two gunslingers, Philip Rivers,
Philip Rivers against a, what's his face said? Jay Cutler's.
A J a j. J color. That's right. Jay Cutler, right?
Am I gonna say his name right. Jade cutlet. I like it.
One guy's a fucking religious frequent 90 kids. The other guys like set him up,
set him up. Let's have another drink, right? Jay Cutler. There you go.
That's right. Jay Cutler. So I'm fucking San Diego had the God damn game one.
Wait, this is, show me a bodybuilder. Is it Jake?
This is the age I'm at now. I don't know anybody's fucking name anymore.
Jay Cutler. There we go.
Or are we?
No, it is Jay Cutler. All right. Whatever the fuck this fucking guy, right?
He key key leads his team down the field.
They go ahead by three points and then San Diego comes down the field.
Philip prevalence, he doesn't give a shit.
You think he's worried about a fucking two minute offense.
This guy's got nine miles to feet. Did you bet you have a nine kids?
Just ski. Just come home to a standing ovation. Everybody's freaking as here.
You have a crowd, you have a fucking crowd of kids. Oh, amazing.
Is that til they all become teenagers and then there's a 10 to 15 year period
where they hated you. You know, you never made sure that I know.
So got staked out. You always sat down on the other end of the table.
They wanted to sit closer to you and he's going to deal with all of that shit.
Right. Um, was it great game, fantastic fucking stadium.
MMM [inaudible]
yeah. Greatness is not a bad seat in the house.
I'm telling you before they moved to some giant monstrosity of a fucking stadium
that this sharing with the rams, I believe. And it's going to fucking, you know,
bankrupt the city.
Um hmm.
Before they fucking do that. [inaudible] if you get a chance,
definitely go to this stuff up center. It's fucking phenomenal. You know,
it's funny, I was, I was sitting,
I was watching the game and I see this guy flying over in this helicopter in the
Robinson 44 during a fucking game. He's,
he looks like he's not even 500 feet off the fucking Griff flies right over the
fucking stadium. And I, with my limited knowledge of aviation,
realized that when there's this big event like that, it's an automatic,
a temporary no fly zone, an hour before and an hour and after the game,
I believe that what is if not two hours before and after, right?
This fucking jerk off flies right over the fucking stadium.
I'm sitting there with my buddy going, ah, that didn't look like a cop. Right?
You can't, I don't think you can fucking do that. I'm just a novice,
but I do not think you could do that. This fucking jerk off comes by again.
He's on his side showing all the passengers down in it and then like two seconds
later, like a police helicopter comes flying over.
I don't know if he got in trouble or what, but uh, I dunno.
I know some pilots listen to this shit. I, like I said,
I don't ever pretend to know anything about that stuff.
As far as my limited knowledge. You are not allowed to do that.
God forbid something happens and then you fucking land on 25,000 people watching
fucking Jay Cutler, right?
With keg booze coming out of his pores going up against, uh,
the other guy from Ash Wednesday, right? Um, uh,
these Kansas city chiefs for real. Uh, so I,
I fucking got a taxi on the way down.
Um,
and then on the way back I called the car service and I'm fucking telling this
guy, I'm like, meet me at one 84 and Avalon. All right,
there's a Kentucky Fried Chicken right next to a donut place.
Can you fucking meet me there? Right? So the guy is like, yeah, that good?
All right, great. Great. All right, so we get down there, right? The game ends.
I walk out there for 15, he's supposed to pick me up at four 30.
I call the guy up, he's like a fucking city block away. Everything's going good.
Then all of a sudden the cops are everything and they're like dead. Like
Uber and Lyft, one 92 guac down that walked down to one 92. Right?
And I'm sitting there going, well, I'm not Uber or Lyft car service. I'm like,
these guys are going to fuck with me. So I try and call this guy.
I call the guy up and I keep telling the guy, he's gone, okay,
I am a block away. I'm a block away and I'm going, yes. Yeah.
I forget the Kentucky the care of. See, I'm going, no, no, no, no, no dokie.
I've Siena. Okay, IFC. There's a donut shop right next door.
I'm going to walk over, see if you can turn in there, and he goes, Oh God, God,
KFC. I'm going, no, no. Listen. I'm walking over and walking over.
I forget he can't walk into the Donald Place.
I'm going to go down to one 92 and Avalon. He goes, okay,
they're parking lot KFC.
He just kept saying that like a prank show and I'm literally getting angry,
yelling. No. One 92 an Avalon into my phone. I'm like,
people with kids had turned around and looking at me,
so I'm trying to put more of a happier tone in my voice and it's just not
working and he just kept going. Okay. A KFC parking lot. I come, no,
one 92 an Avalon. And then I finally go, dude, just repeat it, repeat it.
And he goes, yes, yes. I go, repeat what I said. He goes, one 92 Avalon. I go,
fine, fine. And then like he's calling me back,
pulling into the donut shop and I'm going,
I finally had to fucking take a picture of one 92 on Avalon and send it to the
fucking guy they showed up, right? And he was the greatest guy ever.
Greatest guy ever. And I was like, all right. You know what?
Maybe I got a little emotional. Okay,
there's 25,000 people walking up and down the Goddamn street here.
I don't know what to do here. Maybe, you know, I don't know what,
but I will tell you, when I was at the game, um, GFSI,
when I was at the game, the, uh, these people in front of me,
I've never seen this before. We're drinking a,
what's that Mexican beer that begins with a,
with an m begins with an M bay. It's in a,
it's fucking gold, right? It looks like this looks like a trophy.
It looks delicious, especially after 32 days and not booze.
And so these people in front of me are drinking this shit in and out of a can
and they had this shit, this shit on top. I'm like, what the fuck is that?
Does that crushed red pepper flakes? What is, and this guy next to me, he goes,
Chili powder, they put chili powder around the top because I don't like it.
I'm like, is that like white people put an alignment of fucking corona, I guess?
Yeah, it's something like that. He goes, you know, I don't really like it.
And I was like, well, I gotta try that. I mean, not right now,
but eventually I'm going to try that. Um,
it looked like the shit that you put on, you know,
that are the warning tracks are these new, uh, baseball stadiums.
It's sort of sand and sort of rubber.
That's what it looked like from fucking far away. Um,
so that guy proceeds to get absolutely plastered and after three fucking,
um, quarters,
he comes back up and yells to the crowd that they stopped serving beer at the
start of the fourth quarter and he's yelling about how dumb it is. And, uh,
that's one of those moments where as good that I also wasn't drunk cause I
would've been like, yeah buddy,
you're the reason you're the fucking reason they do that because you can't hold
your alcohol. Look at you. You're a fucking mess.
So actually went to this game and this is like a record for me.
I didn't have any booze and I didn't eat any of the shit food.
I had like two handfuls of fucking peanuts and drank like three waters.
That's it.
Okay.
Because I can't be a fat fuck in this thing, you know, so, um,
I fucking go downstairs and take a Piss, right? Yeah.
And he's this fucking guy just yelling at the police and there's like two cops
there and then there's three, and then there's five. And I'm walking by.
I go down and take a piss and I come back and there is like half the police
force is standing there and is this white dude screaming at all of these cops
screaming,
you gotta do some go up there and do some none other white guys yell at Dude.
It was like total white guy moment like yelling at fucking 20 cops.
He's not getting the shit kicked out of them. And they actually listened to it,
went up, they'd kicked two guys out.
The other guys were like really fucking like, all right. They just sort of left.
I don't know what they did. I Dunno what the fuck they did.
It was the weirdest thing was the two guys screaming,
looking like the ones that were going to get fucking arrested. Um,
but we're demanding that these cops go up and do something.
And then they finally fucking did and they threw these guys up.
It's really bizarre day, but I'm, but once again,
a phenomenal fucking a sports experience if you go there. So, um,
I apologize. A lot of this shit is going to be all sports stuff.
That's kind of what I did this weekend.
I kind of hung out with the daughter and I just watched a bunch of sports and
uh,
did anybody put it on the NFL network and watch Dan Marino of football life.
It was fucking amazing.
But like you can't do the Dan Marino story in fucking 30 minutes.
That should have been an hour and a half long at least. And as much as he fine,
I feel like the finally got his fucking do as you're watching Troy Aikman pate
manning, Brett Farve, all of them saying this was the guy,
this was the fucking guy.
Then finally putting to bed this whole thing that you know that because he
didn't want a Superbowl,
like that's some sort of like black mark up against the guy's fucking name,
the guy, he was so ahead of his time,
he was such an unbelievable fucking quarterback. It took 25 years,
a quarter of a century.
Any massive change in the rules of passing and how you could defend against the
past for people to start fucking with what this guy did from 1983 on.
Um, he was unbelievable.
You know what kills me is his dad taught him how to throw ball, come,
the arm comes up, ball comes out.
And I can't even tell you how many times as a patriots family played him twice a
fucking year. I thought Andre tip had had him, he's armed with the football,
would still be at his waist and Andre was bringing his fucking arm down to get
them and somehow his armored come up and it'd be out 40 odd fucking laser.
Oh my God. He used to kill us.
He used to kill for all you young dolphin fans out there.
That fucking Tom Brady. You know,
cause he's been beating your ass two games a year for like almost his whole
career. Just about, um, that's payback for Dan Marino.
I'm telling you,
Dan Marino today in his prime would easily throw for over 6,000 yards easily.
And if you could actually win without having a running game,
which you can nowadays, the way they fucking game has changed,
he would have at least one Superbowl ring. Okay. I'm telling you, um,
one of my favorites of fucking all time and I'm glad they finally did, uh,
the football life and I think it was at least an hour too short. All right,
there you go. I've said my piece that's coming from a patriots fan too.
And when he played, I fucking hated him because he killed us.
I didn't really hate him, but you know what I mean? I wasn't pleased with him.
All right, let me do the little bit of the, uh,
something has to break up this sport. Stop guys. I gotta,
I gotta do the fucking, I gotta do the reads here. Um, alright. Oh, Jesus. Oh,
here we go. Oh, the unholy matrimony is sports and gambling.
It's not even an unholy man. It's just always been there.
And I'm glad that the NFL is finally fucking addressed it finally address their
fan base. You know, we like football.
We like tits and ass and we, we like to, uh, you know,
fuck with our mortgage payment every month. All right.
Draftkings everybody fantasy football season is almost here.
How old is this copy? It is here and there's no better way.
Yeah.
Uh, to get closer to the game,
you love them with draftkings one week fantasy football draft kings is hosting a
$100,000 contest that is totally free to enter.
And if you draft the perfect lineup, you can,
you can win $1 billion with draftkings.
You can, well, you can basically when, what Netflix earns in a month,
isn't that incredible?
Yeah.
$1 billion. You could actually finance a month of war, uh,
with draft kings there before taxes. After that you could,
you could finance a conflict with draft kings. There are many ways to play,
choose between public contest with big cash prizes. Go against the big boys.
Yeah. Or private contests where you can compete against a group of your friends.
Drive kings also has beginner in casual casual contest.
Will you play against people of a similar skill level?
The best part is you get to draft. Everybody at that level is wearing sandals.
You know, let's try to break it so people don't get low self esteem here.
The best part is you get to draft a new team each week without any commitment.
So get to drive creeks.com now and use Promo Code Bar B U R R to play in draft
kings free week one contest. What the fuck? Why am I reading this?
What the a hundred thousand dollars a year? You can still try to win a billion,
right? Whatever. Just go play fucking draftkings right?
A Promo Code bar@draftkings.com eligibility restrictions apply,
which judging from their past means their employees can't play a c
draftkings.com for details. Oh No, they used to play the other one, I think.
Alright. Everybody had helix. Alix, uh, you know something.
There are a ton of online mattress retailers popping up these days.
All with a one size fits all solution to a better sleep. You know what?
I had no idea.
I do not have my ear to the ground in the fucking mattress retail.
I didn't realize there was a whole bunch of these people popping up. Oh my God.
If there's another online mattress retailer, guess what?
One size doesn't fit all. All right. He likes sleep.
Offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences and s a s in sleeping style
that won't set you back. Thousands of dollars, dollars.
Go to Helen's sleep.com/bar. Take their simple two to three minutes sleep quiz.
They'll build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing that you've ever slept on. Um,
nonliving I should say. Uh, for couples,
they've even personalized each side of the mattress at the beginning of the end
of the relationship. Everyone from GQ to cosmopolitan to the New York Times,
they're all talking about helic sleep. And once you try it out,
you'll know why your custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week.
And shipping is completely free. Try It for a hundred nights gross.
If you don't love it, they'll pick it up, gross and refund,
refunding you and fall Jesus Christ. Did they take it to a sperm donor place?
And ring it out. That's how they make their money back in the fucking shipping.
Uh, [inaudible]. Go to healing
sleep.com/bar right now and you get $50 towards your custom mattress.
That's helic sleep.com/bar for $50 off your order.
He likes sleep.com/bar. All right.
What are we going to love to fucking three more? Oh, look who's here.
Oh to do, do me.
[inaudible] me on yelling at a bunch of cops. Doo Doo, Doo Doo.
Brds me undies.
They won't arrest me even though I'm a walk up bottom wide enough.
They don't give a shit that's no and everybody else out because I am white.
Share my balls. Feel good in my privilege. Underwear.
Don't forget about the taint. Sorry.
And I apologize to all Italian Americans offended by that with the without
papers. Do you know what I learned? A A, an a, an Irish wop I never heard of,
which was a Nina.
So Italians that was without papers and India,
India and fucking Irish. Nina was no Irish need apply.
I didn't know that. I had no fucking idea.
This is back in like the gangs in New York. If you're actually offended by that,
you better be 100% Italian. All right? Okay.
Don't come at me with the 15% being 100% offended. Okay.
Um, I'll send you some fucking pro flowers. All right?
Me undies me on these will be the most comfortable underwear pair of underwear
you will ever own.
Made from a sustainably sourced natural soft fabric that's three times softer
than cotton.
What they do is they punch a horse in the head and they cut off its muzzle and
then they put it right down here where your junk is, you know,
and then the horse wakes up permanently smiling for the rest of its life.
That's where the, you know, that's where it comes from.
A lot of people don't know that that's what motel is.
What else could be softer than cotton other than a horse is muscle.
I'm sorry for that image. Okay.
Ultimate feel good on ds for when you want to feel naked.
Not and not be naked for the fellows. Mandy's diamond scene pouch.
Laka rhinestone ball bag. Uh, I almost got to the,
the words there. Uh, this pouch,
the Freddie Mercury themed pouch cradles your jewels.
It gives you a okay mustache and leather hat not included and it gives you stuff
to support it needs without feeling too tight, right?
And the other one bites the dust. Um, ladies,
you will love the soft equal friendly fabric.
Poor would thought your pussy could actually help the environment.
So soft and touch bill 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
They guaranteed you will love your undies or your money back. Right now,
beyond use has an exclusive offer for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free shipping and me undies is so sure you will
love their underwear. They even offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee.
You order a pair and if you don't love your first pair, get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free shipping, 100% satisfaction guarantee.
What in God's name are you waiting for it to get your 20% off free shipping and
their 100% satisfaction guarantee and get the best softest underwear you will
ever own.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's Manny's dot com slash iceberg
this is a limited time offer. So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life according to the copy.
It's time to let me undies change yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar right now.
Okay.
They use a new category.
I wanted to start and I should really fucking know this guy's name.
I want to start a new thing to write in. Okay?
So this podcast doesn't get any more stale than it already is. Um,
is your favorite performances by non stars in movies where you and your friends
still quoted?
It's an unknown fucking actor and you may never even saw him again.
Never even seen the person again. I'm so me. I'm going to kick it off.
I don't even know this actress names. Let me look this up.
He was in resonances of war dogs cop.
Okay
actor. Let's see if I could find the name of this guy. Um,
I don't know what this fucking guy's name is. I got to give him a shout out.
You know, I'm going to hit pause because I want to give this guys shout up.
Okay. Unknown on hail or did unheralded actor. Um,
as far as I know, rich Turner in reservoir dogs.
It's one of my fucking, just one scene actors. I've, I've,
I don't know, I don't watch a ton of movies, but I fucking love this guy.
He plays the cop in the bathroom when, uh, what's his face?
Tim Roth is sitting there with all the drugs and he comes out and this is a dog,
a dog sniff and a the drug sniff dog sniffing drug sniffing dog.
Um, so he was in pulp fiction too,
meaning also, yeah, he wasn't in a lot of movies, but he plays the way he,
he's being the cop and he's telling that story.
Just the way he like the line. I said, buddy,
I'm going to shoot you in the face if you don't put your fucking hands on that
dashboard. That's just the way it's written and the way he did it. He goes,
I said, buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the face if you don't put your fucking hands on that
dashboard. Just the way he said it.
I don't know why that sounds exactly like a fucking cop to me.
So that was like something just me and my friends,
we would be fucking hammered striking out with chicks and you'd just be walking
out to your car and one of your invariably would just go, buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the face. And everyone just started laughing.
You don't put your fucking hands in that dashboard. Who are your favorites?
Who are your favorites? They just had that one thing. You fucking friends.
You still quoted, man. I just knew a bunch of those.
There's obviously a zillion guys.
There's a zillion lines and fucking Po, uh, in um,
Goodfellas by the way. Uh, rest in peace. Frank Vinson,
the first big guy to go from Goodfellows man. I mean, what a,
what an absolute legend. What an absolute legend.
He was as amazing as an actor, as his hair was.
What a head of hair that guy had. Good Lord Jesus Christ.
What a head of hair. That guy had his whole frigging life.
That's what you say when you're bald. You fucking see that on people.
Look at that guy. I Dunno if I ever had that hair.
Some people, you know, some people they just fucking,
I don't know what genes that guy is, that guy,
he must had a Roman emperor or something in his fucking family tree,
credible actor. And so God damn funny,
comedic timing was incredible. Um,
I even loved that commercial. He did one, I think his only line was, oh,
when that guy was like stocking up the freezer and he was disrespected them and
his buddy just kept going, oh,
I'm definitely going to miss him.
And that was definitely somebody on my bucket list. You know, I get in a movie,
I have like fucking two or three lines,
but that was definitely a bucket list to ever be able to do a scene with him.
And what was so cool? Uh, Michael Rappaport, um,
quite possibly the funniest guy in social media right now with this fucking
videos. I was so goddamn funny. Um,
he actually posted a picture on his Twitter account. You should check it out.
I think it's,
I am at ILM Rappaport and it's him working with Frank Vinson in the early
nineties.
It was like really early on and he got a picture of him shine and Frank Vincent
shoes. And he said, uh, at one time, Frank Vincent,
uh, maybe go home and get my shine box.
And what I love was a lot of people now can look back on it as a classic,
and everybody's quoted at a zillion times, but Rappaport I already knew.
Go home and get your fucking shine bucks. He was on that shit early.
Fucking early nineties. Uh, they barely done editing it.
He already knew that that was an instant fucking classic. Uh,
I've gotta get him back on the podcast again. He has so many amazing stories.
Um, anyways, uh, let's skip that. Let me finish this fight.
I had to break up the, uh, podcast reading, I mean, the, uh,
advertising reading. Why do I say the wrong thing first before I correct it?
I Dunno bill. Cause you're dumb because you have a zillion things on your mind.
I know. Fair enough. All right. Dollar Shave club, everybody.
What you might not know, there's a lot of things you do know,
but what you might not know, I said Buddy,
is that dollar shave club also also has products for pretty much everything else
you need in the bathroom. Body Wash, shampoo, Hair Gel,
don't need any of that. Lip Balm, everything. What am I going to Moose,
my pubes uh, at the store.
There are too many options and you can't tell the difference between any of
them. Then if you have any questions,
that clerk usually doesn't know the difference or it's still running the fucking
cash register. They can't help you anyways. All right,
well dollar shave club makes it easy and convenient for you to upgrade your
shave and your bathroom. Do I have the hiccups?
All of a sudden now you don't have to step foot in a store to get high quality
shave and grooming products. This is right here. Why?
I would never invest in a fucking strip mall. I swear to God,
I don't know what's going. I know where these kids are going to meet, you know,
to get away from their fucking parents when all the malls go away and
everybody's just getting this shit delivered by drones. Uh,
now you don't have to step foot in new fucking mar at dollar shave club delivers
them right to your door just like their raises.
Everything is super high quality and we'll leave you looking and feeling amazing
from premium ingredients to sophisticated cents.
Dollar Shave clubs is changing the game.
If you're sick of the nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try out dollar shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving away their shit.
Shower shave started set two new members for only five bucks.
This start is set features their executive razor and three trial size versions
of their most popular products that help you stay fresh and clean.
How much are the heterosexual women of the world loving that they're doing this
ladies, if you guys stinks, just buy him the shit. Shower,
shave packet for Christmas and stuff in the stocking with a cute little note
that says take a hint and you draw a little smiley face. Um,
and your first box you will receive their shave butter,
body wash and one wipe Chally butt wipes.
You will also receive their executive razor, which includes their premium,
weighty, weighty handle and a full cassette of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cart cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offer is exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar that's dollar
shave club.com/burr dollar shave clubs, high quality products.
Woo.
We'll have you covered from face to cheek to butt cheeks from face cheeks to
butt cheeks. I fuck up that joke every week.
There is no better time to try the club. And lastly, but certainly not least,
Lee.
Okay.
The classic, the Robert Deniro, the original, the Pachino,
the mall and bramble stamps.com everybody stamps save you time and they save you
money, which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter.
Yeah,
package. I'm trying to be interesting with my line read like that Guy Buddy.
I will shoot you any pact. I'm going to read the next fucking sentence.
The way he broke that up. Let me just finish this one first.
Any package using my computer and printer and the mailman to pick it up, right?
Yeah,
the hassle, the post office in May.
Let me think for the postcode I kid still can't do. It.
Doesn't have a rhythm and everything from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account and minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitment.
stamps.com will even help you decide the best class of mail or your um,
based on your needs. No need to lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com whenever I send out my posters cause we've got a whore myself
out at the NOI shows for a couple of bucks. I'm a moron if I can figure out.
So can you in right now?
You too can enjoy stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in
Berbee. You are that stamps.com and tuber.
All right. All right, well let's get back to what the fuck. Okay.
Formula One. Did you think I wasn't gonna talk about Formula One.
What'd you think I was gonna talk about how Mississippi,
Mississippi State fucking trans my LSU Tigers.
You know another one of my favorite teams,
SMU given away 56 pounds per player on the fucking offensive and defense
offensive line against TCU. C'Mon frogs.
How SMU was whipping that fucking horn tone ass for fucking the first half
before they wore him down. He just leaned on him.
Um,
do you think I was going to congratulate the Cleveland Indians in an unprecedent
22 in a row? Does that what you thought I was going to do?
You think I was gonna do all of that and I was going to talk about that Formula
One race down in fucking that race made me sick to one of my favorite races of
the year. It's at night. It's in Singapore. It's one of the most beautiful,
amazing slash kind of freak me out cities I've ever been to in my life slash
countries. Um, it really is one of the most beautiful,
like amazing fucking city where you just feel like you're overbearing.
Parents are home all the time. Um,
it was fucking rain. It was night. It was raining out. Okay.
The Ferrari's were running great. Daniel Ricardo was running great.
Mercedes wasn't doing that well, you know,
I don't know if Hamilton had a fucking, I thought it was all tied up.
Maybe he was up by three points. I can't remember.
The Ferrari needed to show up on this fucking day. Alright.
And if you watched when they were doing the time trials on Saturday and you sell
what it's like trying to drive behind somebody doing 0050607080 fucking miles an
hour with that fucking rooster tail of water coming up.
I mean it was going to be an unbelievable fucking race.
God knows whoever's in fucking first place and then first turn is going to win
the Goddamn race. Alright,
so Sebastian Vettel the Ferrari's they get first and third.
Alright, with Daniel Ricardo, the red bull is in second fucking place.
I believe that's the way it was, right? Fucking Mercedes,
a back and forth and fifth. So the Goddamn race starts
offer our, he has to do,
all he's got to do is just make it to the first turn and first fucking place
unscathed. He's going to win this fucking race. Okay? Worst case scenario,
Hamilton gets fucking second place. That's only 18 points.
Federal is going to get 25 he'll pick up fucking, you know, whatever.
What is that seven points? The fucking race starts
Kimmy Reagan, and he acted like fucking Greg Brady when, when he,
when the pressure was on to beat him,
gotta beat Marcia gotta get close to that quarter of an inch.
He fucking stomps on the guests, tries to go around. Oh, I'm sorry.
It was Max for stappen.
Not Daniel Ricard tries to go around the guy that fucking tires get all fucking
in a locked there and they fucking go up and over.
He fucking fucks up his car,
slams the fucking red bull car into his fucking teammate.
The other Ferrari Vettel makes it to the first turn unscathed.
Meanwhile, fucking not on skate, but he makes it there,
but it's his car's fucked up and got hit in the back. Meanwhile,
fucking lose fucking Hamilton. He drives right around this shit rays.
He sneaking by fuck head comes back in with this fucked up car. Greg Brady,
right smashes in to the fucking red bull guy again.
And who does he hit? He hits the fucking Alfonso in the fucking orange car.
Try and do the exact same thing as Lewis Hamilton,
but Lewis Hamilton's the Derek Jeter fucking star child,
just blessed 3000 hit the eight a fucking grand slam one of these guys
and fucking Vettel drives like, you know,
two more turns in the whole front of his car, comes off both Ferrari's,
out of the fucking race. They were in first and third place at first and fourth.
I can't like, I don't remember.
They had them,
they had them and they let off the hook.
They were both out of the race before it even fucking started.
And all I could think is what my dad used to always say when somebody would do
something like that, you'd be on crisis guy. Like that guy I that guy,
you could fuck up a free lunch.
That's the first expression that popped in my head at that.
I think I tweeted it. I was so fucking pissed.
Ferrari could fuck up a free lunch. I mean that was a free lunch.
No one could drive fast at day.
Mercedes weren't running well the whole fucking weekend. So what do you do?
You take out yourself and you fucking teammate you clear out the whole fucking
front row
for fucking Lewis Hamilton who just drives along unscathed.
That Guy Louis Hamilton is a blessed man.
That's one of those deals. He's one of those guys.
Makes you believe in a higher power like this.
Just somebody that just fucking loves. I mean,
I know I'm taking away all the preparation that man does, but
you know,
he cuts around the outside, no problem. Alphonso goes through the same thing.
His fucking day's over. Unbelievable.
And then the rest of the race and riding around the fucking rain and Hamilton
fucking winds. No problem. Unfucking believable.
They, I wanted to see a race. I knew that Hamilton was going to try to fucking,
he wasn't going to be happy sitting in, you know, all the way back there. Right.
Who would be right.
I wanted to see what the fuck he was going to do with this car.
Not doing that well and all of that rain. What'd he actually crash? I mean,
you know, he's going to drip, push it to the fucking limit.
All of that was out of the second.
It started like remember that year that jets was supposed to be good in like
fucking 99 and like the first game Vinny tested verde goes back and blows out as
Achilles and then key Sean was crying after the game.
That was the original. That's my quarterback. That was the original.
Um,
that's what it was like. I still watched the fucking race. It was still fucking,
it was still exciting by Jesus Christ. Um, anyways,
and then I also, I watched the boxing.
That's all I do this weekend is I just fucking watched a brain in an episode.
F is for family.
So I just stayed in the whole fucking weekend when I wasn't riding.
I was just watching sports and uh,
I'm not a big box and guy just because I've gotten fucked over so many times in
the paper views. Uh, so forgive me if I fuck up.
The pronunciation is a glove kin first.
Canelo and uh, that took me back.
That's what paper view boxing used to be.
I'm not saying he didn't get fucked every once in a while back then,
but it was just too, they was fucking forehead to forehead, just it was a war,
feeling each other out, respecting each other and all that shit. And then, uh,
the usual bullshit happened.
You know how that fucking lady sot one 18 to one 10. I mean, I, I you, Jesus, I,
I don't know shit about boxing. And I was like, what the fuck? Um,
and I loved how Roy Jones in the fucking end goes like, I, he goes,
I loved that it was a draw, you know,
cause that means we get to see this again and next time there's definitely gonna
be a decision. And I, I fell, it felt like he was like,
they were like, Roy, don't bring this up.
This is the Illuminati script of boxing. Please don't bring this shit up. It's,
this whole fucking thing is, uh, that it was going to be a drive.
We had any way to make this thing be a fucking draw so we could do it again.
Um, but it was great. I was a great fucking fight. It's,
I thought a glove can clearly won the fight. Um,
I just thought he was backing up the whole fucking time. And, uh,
I know Kendall had some big shots towards the end,
but he glove could just fucking walk. He ate them all up. He ate 'em up.
He just Guinea would back off for a second.
You just come back and then he would fucking give him, you know, if he took two,
we'd come back and give him two. I just thought, you know, I dunno,
I agreed with too, that, that fucking guy who screams all the time.
No, I got the bike. [inaudible]
that guy always screaming. Uh,
do they have him in the crowd so we can't hear himself?
Does he not have headsets on? I love that he yells every fucking time. Um,
I dunno. I thoroughly enjoyed it. The decision obviously stuck,
but I did not feel that I got fucked on my money.
I feel like the fighters got fucked. And, uh,
I retweeted this rant that Teddy Atlas went on and, um,
it was, you know, somebody has to say,
so I just don't understand how it's still that corrupt. It's just they've never,
like, it was weird, like Vegas was totally corrupt and totally mobbed up.
And then they cleaned it up by putting those corporations in there who then
fucked you on everything, including the steak.
Yeah.
Why can't they clean up boxing?
Can they get the mob out of this so that the corporations can come over on the
legal side of stealing and fuck people more than they ever have? Maybe the app,
I have no idea. I don't understand it,
but a teddy atlas said, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Butcher. And how he said it, he said,
those guys went in the ring and came out less of who they were.
Meaning that they, they, you do permanent damage to yourself.
Meanwhile, they will break it down the a, they will break it down,
the power shots and all of that type of shit.
It's like I was watching Rogan's recap of it
with Jim Norton and, uh,
Rogan read some stats where this guy, he took, okay. You know, here's the,
blew his head. He took 118 punches to the fucking head.
I haven't taken 118 punches to the head my life.
My bolded brother used to beat the shit out of me all the time,
but we knew you kept it to the body.
That's what your father wouldn't see it when he came home. Um, so,
but other than that, I mean it was, it was great.
It was everything that I knew that may, whether, and, um,
McGregor wasn't going to be,
and that's why I didn't rent it and that's why I spent my money on that.
I still got fucked.
Um,
but, uh, is Tommy Morrison still alive? Okay.
I have to hit pause on this cause I gotta watch this shit.
He's a relative of fucking,
okay.
John Wayne, in case you didn't know. I'm sorry. He's a boxer back in the day.
Uh, all right. I got to read some of the, uh, shit here for this week.
I can't see anything here doing this in my fucking living room.
We bought these things when, when we, uh,
yet another thing I had fixed on this house,
say these fucking awful lights on the wall. So we bought these sconces,
these really fancy fucking things. And the thing,
the fancy thing in front of the light is so God damn thick that it,
it always seems like it's on a dimmer.
They probably should have just bought a higher what? Bulb?
Yeah,
I dunno. This has gotta be one of those moments where you're like,
why the fuck am I listening to this guy?
He's talking about the fucking light bulbs in his living room. I'm sorry.
All right. DNA testing at Ravens game. No boy,
dear bill, I love the podcast. Love you. Stand up a love F is for family.
Thank you.
I have to start promoting that at my standup shows too because I feel like a lot
of people still don't know the shows on. Um, so if you get a chance to be,
give the show, tell your friends about it and everything,
just so we can continue doing the show will be awesome. Um, you said,
I wanted to hear your opinion on this very weird giveaway at Sunday's ravens
game.
I'm a season ticket holder for the ravens and it's not unusual to get the little
freebies when you ant the stadium. Commemorative coins, beer, koozies flags,
et Cetera. Uh,
Sunday is the home opener and some company is giving away free DNA tests.
So I guess has happened yesterday. Free DNA test. What are you trying to do?
Figure out if you're a fucking human being. Um,
and it's not even some ancestry.com type shit that could give you some semi
useful information.
You're not getting any useful information from ancestry.com they're doing what
this company's doing. I don't know what they're doing,
but they're not trying to help you out.
Do you really need to know how much Scottish blood you have in you that you
really need one? So what you can do, what?
Go out and go feel justified buying a fucking kilt. You're not Scottish,
you're a mud.
Yeah.
Um, the article I linked says, uh,
they're testing for four genes.
The test offers insight into your mind, body and health is what they claim.
It seems like this company wants a bunch of data and they figured that an NFL
game is a great way to get 70,000 mouth breathing fucking morons. Um, that,
that part was me. 70,000 people deed to 70,000 people's DNA all at once.
Uh, the company has also partnered with the 49ers.
So testing might come to San Francisco soon. What are your thoughts?
Keep up the good work and go fuck yourself. Ah,
I think I know exactly what this is.
Um,
in the future, people's DNA is going to be,
it's just starting to become a revenue source.
The way your phone number and all of this other shit that they get from you at
cvs and all these fucking places.
It was another revenue stream where you are buying shaving cream, tampons,
whatever the fuck you doing.
And then they would get personal information from you that then they could then
sell to other fucking companies. Um,
I think it is now that they've exhausted all of that.
They've now moving onto fingerprints, face recognition in DNA,
and they're going to share this with everybody. And, uh,
I know the robots are coming. I don't know how to,
I don't know where this all lands.
I know that there's talks in the future that human beings could be meshed with
robots.
Um,
if I had to guess,
they're probably gonna get to the point where with your DNA they can grow
another you and say, well that's not really you.
The real you is going to the ravens game.
So we're going to do all kinds of Nazi doctors,
Nazi doctor s type experiments on this with the fucking robot before we released
this to the public. That's where I think it's going.
All right.
Okay.
And you know,
I don't want my twin adult brother coming into this world at 51 years of age
cause I figured another two years they'll probably start doing it
and getting a fucking, you know,
bionic arm put on and he's screaming and fucking Panke has,
God knows they're not gonna use fucking anesthetic cause that fucking
okay.
DNA version.
You will be the property of a corporation and we'll have no rights to fucking
um,
anesthetic.
Yeah.
Why don't I write Scifi? You know,
I did the whole fucking thing about how you had to take a test and if she
flunked the test on the population control,
you just walk into the ocean and now there's a movie coming out about that.
I don't know, maybe I'm just not original.
Maybe I should start writing these fucking things and that sounds like a cool
fucking movie, right? Uh, you have to go save yourself.
You know,
Hollywood do some fucking creepy happy ending where you're just staring there
yourself touching each other's face and everybody's fucking crying.
Um,
I dunno, you throw Willsmith in there somehow it's a winner. All right.
Whiny fan complaining. Alright, how do you bill,
I'm a four year podcast listener and I saw you love and San Antonio earlier this
year.
I think you're a layers guy and obviously it's your podcast and I should go fuck
myself, but I think your Trump positions are kind of unfair. Um,
okay. I'm not another political fucking person.
He did call himself off for being,
I think your Trump positions are kind of unfair.
Well then you think my Hillary ones are fair. All right. God bless you. Um,
I know you're just a comedian.
I know you have a lot of fans in the quote real America. Oh,
there's the left talking down to the right. Okay.
And so you have to toe a line.
Isn't this, this is the classic,
I really helped the person who wrote this as listening. Sir, you're,
and you are inventing all of this in your head because you're upset about
something politically. Okay?
Are you mad at what I'm talking about about Trump?
Is that what this is that you feel?
I have to tow some sort of fucking white liberal line because I'm out here in
Hollywood. Um, but Trump is,
to my mind, obviously a dangerous guy.
I won't go through my whole list of grievance grievances,
but he thinks climate change is a Chinese hoax.
Uh,
supports white supremacists and just this week through the lives of 800,000,
what am I going to make sure he didn't use any comments?
8 million people who are brought here as children into disarray.
And I know every president has skeletons, but even a liberal like me,
Oh, is it?
Hillary person can see this guy is nothing like w w or George H.
Uh, dude, when did I say I liked this guy? I never did.
I never said that. I liked the guy.
I just said people freaking out of bottom and losing their fucking shit.
I should've been more specific like fucking white people acting like the needle
in your life was gonna change that fucking far. All right. By the way,
um, you know, if you really want to see a bunch of skeleton,
both of these people, I mean, this election was essentially 2:00 AM at a bar.
I mean, you had to go home with somebody, right? Probably shouldn't have. Um,
listen, this fucking guy thinks climate change is a hoax. Fine. Alright.
Hillary was all for bailing out these fucking banks in 2008,
which is exactly what the fuck happened.
And all these people who stayed in Florida riding out the fucking storm and
everybody's making fun of them and saying how dumb they are for staying there.
They're probably upside down in their house and unlike the bankers don't have
another house that they can go to. Yeah. Evacuate the area and do what?
Go with half of the Florida and sit in a fucking waffle house in Georgia.
And then what? I don't have enough gas money to get back.
I love the complete lack of sympathy for people that can completely fucked in
2008. Okay. Um,
which Hillary was totally all about.
She was also all about fucking, you know,
ignoring the wishes of the people on the left who voted more for fucking Bernie
Sanders according to this trial and colluded with the Democratic Party to ignore
those votes and box Bernie Sanders out in.
And she just took the nomination and all of a sudden she's got the fucking balls
to sit here and talk about the electoral college. Okay?
She's not a good person either. And I'm not saying w is I told you I was done.
I want to say WME, sorry, Donald Trump.
I said I was done with Donald Trump when he said that both sides can take
contributed to the violence,
that he couldn't even get himself to say that those Nazis might be a little out
of their fucking minds. The neonazis. I told you I was done with the guy. Okay,
but you hate the guy so much. You're hearing what you want to hear. All right?
Maybe I don't try to trash Trump enough on this podcast,
but I don't feel that I need to. Everybody,
at least in my profession has a bit on how fucking stupid the guy is.
Billion dry mouth talking about this shit. So I don't, and for you to sit there,
you fucking content. After four years of listening to my podcast,
acting like I told some sort of line. Did you?
Do you ever listen to my fucking advertising?
I lose advertisers all the fucking time. Okay.
If I was towing some sort of line,
I would read those things like I was on fucking Lawrence Welk, hype and Geritol.
I don't. Okay.
I told a line as far as I say, what the fuck? I think it's funny.
That's the line that I am towing here, sir. I'm sorry.
The guy that you wanted to fucking win didn't fucking win. I know. I know.
Trump's out of his fucking mind and I don't need you wagon.
You fucking finger at me. Give me a God damn fucking lecture
is if I don't understand that this guy's fucked up. Okay,
so why don't you look at your own up your own fucking skirt.
Okay.
It'd be a little more even handed all you fucking guys. I mean,
I guess you got to whine about Trump because he's actually the fucking president
of Jesus Christ. The fucking pass.
I don't know what the fuck it is that Hillary gets is unbelievable.
Ps, Hillary sucks. That's all I get on this side. You know, he said, look man,
I just think that despite what you're saying about being comedian,
you do have a platform. Fuck you buddy. Fuck you.
You're not putting that on me. All right. I can tell you this right now, dude.
If you get your political information from a fucking standup comedian who can't
even read out loud,
you use this thing to decide who the leader of the free world is going to be.
I can't help you. What am I supposed to do? Do you know what I would say to you?
Send you fucking DNA to the ravens.
I'm anyways, you do have a platform.
And while I'd never dare to tell you what to say,
I hope you will consider what happens when you play down the danger of his
behaviors. Um, let me ask you this.
What exactly would be happening now if the other fucking bought and paid for
fucking Twat went in there? What do you think would happen?
What do you think would happen? Huh? Do you honestly,
when, while she admits that global warming is real, what do you think?
What happened? Do you think she's going to do anything?
Most the most she could be in there for is eight. Fuck. They just wait them out.
Al Gore in 1992 said that there has to be a car that gets at least a hundred
miles a gallon by the fucking year, 2000, something like that.
And it just kept delaying the project and delaying it and delaying and delaying
and delaying it. And then they were out of office and it just fucking went away.
There you go. So I don't know what to tell you. I have to tell you buddy.
Um, I always vote outside of the democratic and the Republican Party.
Okay. Unless I find somebody within them,
like a Bernie Sanders who I feel will actually,
hopefully make more people within those bought and paid for fucking groups.
Uh, I dunno, take a stand for fucking regular people. I mean, that's what I do.
Okay. I don't like Trump. The guy makes me sick to my stomach. I think he's a,
I absolutely think the guy's fucking racist. Uh,
but I also think Hillary is the fucking devil.
And in a lot of ways we sidestepped a bunch of other shit. Okay.
We walked into a bunch of this shit with Trump, but you definitely stepped up.
Come on man. Everybody,
anybody with any remote sense of intelligence knows that, you know,
that was the fucking Blue Bonnet bull. All right. That wasn't the fucking,
that wasn't Alabama verse fucking Clemson or Shit. That was a, you know,
that was the holiday bowl election. Alright. Actual money based on I, I,
you know, and I dunno, I dunno why you needed to send me that dude. You,
you honestly think that I want to see fucking kids get sent out of this country.
I don't, I don't. Okay, so stop turning me into the fucking,
you know what it is? Do you want this country's fucked out.
There's a guy who can't read out loud that does a podcast twice a week.
And I'm telling you that is,
if we could just get him to politically say what we feel,
I think we could turn this country around. We're taking collars.
I said, buddy, um, actual money based on gold. Hey,
Billy gold bullets.
That'd be great.
Have some gold bullocks in that fucking diamond and crusted pouch.
I was listening to Rogan's podcast recently and he had a guy called Peter Shift
on and he was talking about gold money.com.
This is basically a private gold reserve where you can buy gold,
which is held in a secure vault. Oh, is it?
Listen, you give us our money and we'll have, we'll hold your gold.
Great. So they keep my cash and the gold.
Do I got to send them a donkey to and using a prepaid mastercard,
you can pay for goods and services with your money backed by gold or platinum if
you'd rather buy that. I would do that immediately.
Or when the dollar crash is effectively what the banks used to do
before they sold the foundations of our currency here is here in the UK.
Gordon Brown sold all the diamonds that back sterling,
uh, when the bank shit the bed. Um,
I don't know what any of that means here in the UK. Gordon Brown,
who's Gordon Brown? Or is that a bank
like fucking j p Morgan sold all the diamonds that back sterling when the banks
shit the bed. Oh, okay. So you got your money back.
Cause I was saying I just this minute signed up to something,
a commercial and I'll be putting some money into it,
although not all my money as it's always best to diversify when you stash your
saving.
I think it is much better than bitcoin as it's actually based on something of
value. I love you to go fuck yourself, sir.
Why don't you just take your money and go buy a gold coin?
Why don't you just do that?
Why don't you take your paper and go buy some gold and leave with the gold
rather than giving your money to this fucking person you're not gonna meet.
And he tells you that he has. How do you know there's gold there?
He's basically doing what they're doing with Fort Knox where they say there's
all this golden there and then there's rumors that it's fucking empty. Um,
I liked the direction you're going in, but, uh,
I think you a went out of the frying pan into the fire with that one grant.
I don't want to shit on whatever that guy's doing because I got your abridged
version of it. But um,
that reminded me of that movie blow where Johnny Depp's character gives them $2
million in cash and they give them a book that says $2 million on it.
Then he goes to jail. He never gets his fucking money. All right.
My girlfriend's daughter is causing us to break up.
Is that a bad thing? Um, Jesus Christ. I mean,
you're already dating somebody that already has a kid,
so that's going to be Ari a hundred times harder to make that fucking work.
And then the kid doesn't even like you. So I mean,
maybe she's doing a solid here. Um, hey bill.
Okay, here we go. So my girl and I have seven years,
both worked for the same company and I was offered a better position in Florida
and she was also offered a position as well.
Now here's where the daughter comes in and fucks up the flow. Yeah,
cause she fucking probably wants to stay at her school.
Her daughter's 14 is just starting.
High schoolers are foods refusing to move and her mother is going along with not
forcing her to move and is going to pass her, is going to pass in our position.
We agreed I will not move down and get things in order until she wait.
We agreed.
I will move down and get things in order until she gets there in four years now
for the past few weeks we've been getting into more fights and our reasoning for
the fight is sit down for this one bill.
She says it's easier for me to leave when she's mad.
She's fighting you because it's easier for you to leave when she's mad.
I think that's the dumbest fucking reason I've ever heard.
Also she keeps saying,
I'm going to go down and find myself some black ass and ended up cheating on her
while I'm there.
We'd love to get your take on this situation and get your insight on what I
should do. Thanks and pick up a fucking drink. You Pussy.
Fuck A, I would say a,
yeah,
I'd say there's a staggering lack of trust. Um,
okay.
I think the key here is to not get into an argument with her as to just sit down
and try and discuss it with her and just say, listen,
um,
we agreed that this is what I was going to do and now what it is is I know,
I think this is what happened. What she did was,
is she did what was best for her daughter and she put herself with you in
second,
but she still sounds like cares about you and the fact that you're down there
and she's worried that you're going to leave and she misses you.
I think that that's what's happening. So I would just ask her,
is this some like misdirected anger? I will.
You're actually just saying that you miss me and you love me.
Is that what you say in it? We could work through this.
And then if you're really not going to fuck around,
we're honor and you're really going to see it through,
then you want to be able to just say, listen, I'll do whatever it takes.
I'm going to be there in four years. If you're not lying,
I think you ought to be able to work your way through it. And um,
I think this has less to do with the daughter than it has to do with the fact
that she just misses you and she's afraid that you're going to find somebody
else down there. Evidently wherever you moved where a,
there's a bunch of black ass down there.
Okay.
That's what I would guess. So I,
you guys need to get on the same page and you'd have an honest moment with
yourself before you fucking slowly tear the bandaid off.
Either get the fuck out of it or totally commit to her. Um, I mean,
seven years at this point. Why aren't you dropping a fucking ring on her
that to shut her up for a good couple of weekends. Um,
it won't shut her up permanently. I can tell you that right now. Oh,
I can tell you some stories. Yeah.
So
can I tell you so, oh, sit right back in a [inaudible] latte live.
May read guy who jumps through all the fucking hoops and still gets the evil
light. All right, Mike.
Okay.
Uh, my wife is, uh, who, uh, dear bill Billy butter tits.
Fuck you on losing weight. Uh, my wife,
my wife decided to have an affair four months ago. Oh boy.
Before I knew what was going on,
she told me she didn't know if she wanted to be married to me anymore and that
it was because I was too controlling.
And by controlling,
she means I told her as a stay at home mom,
I had expectations.
I expected her to keep the house clean and take care of our children as we
agreed when she quit her job. Yeah. I mean,
which is a totally fair ask,
you know, but nowadays in this world of hyper fucking feminism,
not all feminists are bad, but the fucking, the uh,
the god is great fucking crazy ones there. Um, yeah,
they would say that that was sexist. That you know, well,
why don't you work all fucking day and then come home and also have the house
clean. You know what I mean? Let me look. If you got a bunch of kids,
it can only be so fucking clean, but at least you could do is order a pizza.
Right? Um, anyways,
I would come home to her friends being at the house and her drinking all
afternoon while Jesus Christ. She's not even making an effort. Yeah.
This is what happens when you draft in the first round buddy. You know,
you get those second rounders, they, they got some to fucking proof. You know,
that's just what happens when you marry a temp. I'm assuming she's good looking.
If you putting up with this shit,
I would get home from work after being gone 15 hours and have to say something
about how I felt that the house was a wreck and there was no dinner in sight.
It never seemed to matter.
Back in January we moved to Denver from Atlanta thinking everything would be
better.
And she met this 25 year old guy who she proceeded to sneak around behind my
back with and bring our children around. No Way.
I'm 38 she's 35 we have two children and we've been married for almost 12 years.
Yeah, Dude. Yeah. This is a wrap. Yeah,
and now she wants a divorce,
a plans to move this kid into our home with our children.
Oh my God, Dude. This is the worst person ever.
I am beside myself with the thought of the divorce and this punk kid living with
my children. Oh my God. I know it won't last,
but the fact is I don't want my children to be around this piece of shit,
let alone living in my house. She think this is,
she thinks this is perfectly okay to put the kids in I through this.
I do love her and would do anything to save our marriage,
but the truth is she's delusional at this point and I guess I am too.
What do I do this? Stop this.
I know this is not my fault because I busted my ass to build the life she always
dreamed of. Only for her to think she can kick me out of it.
Any advice and or the lovely nick you could give would be greatly appreciated.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Yeah, man. I mean this is the things,
this is what can happen to a guy.
Um,
but you're not allowed to talk about this on television are you never,
never, never. You can talk about guys being overbearing, domestic violence,
all those things that should be brought to light. They will not talk about this.
You Watch Dr Phil talk about this. You want you to blame the guy.
So she saying Lou reason that she saw to his cock was because you weren't paying
enough attention to her.
You need to try to pay attention more to her. Well,
she sucking his dick. Um,
what do I do to stop this? I don't know. Um,
okay.
At this point I would be thinking about my kids
and how I could
make this as look to,
this is what the fuck she wants to do. This is what the fuck she wants to do.
How you make this as easy to fucking transition your fucking divorce. Uh,
I could tell you this, I know you called her a whore here.
Don't ever say that to your kids, cause at the end of the day,
it's still their mother and you gotta fucking, you know,
you got to look the other way. Um, I dunno dude, this is,
this is outside my fucking realm. Um,
I can tell you this dude, you fucking 38 years old.
You sound like a great fucking guy. Um,
I would just, whatever you got to do for your kids, I would do that.
Her is a fucking lost cause. All right.
And I would, um, yeah,
I would do that and I would start [inaudible] and go out and get yourself a
fucking beautiful, goodhearted fucking woman. I haven't, I,
I'll maybe even if you have time,
I would go to therapy and figure out how the fuck you ended up,
unless she's just a total psycho, like,
so you don't go out and fucking marry that again. Um, figure that out.
But the fuck, I'm trying to marry you off already. Jesus Christ. You,
you just getting out of something. I don't know dude.
This my head spinning over this one cause I'm putting myself in your shoes.
I don't know what the fuck I would do. Um,
oh man, that's a rough one. Some other fucking guy going in
telling your kids to pipe down. I mean, Jesus fucking Christ. Uh,
yeah, I would, I would, uh,
I would talk to somebody about this way beyond my fucking educational level.
That's what I would do. I hope you get through this thing and uh,
what a fucking mistake she's making. I can tell you that,
but she did the way you described it. Granted, I'm gonna get your side of it.
She does not sound like the point a person that even when she does fuck it up,
she'll admit it. She probably still put it on you and uh,
but you know what?
It'll all come out in the wash and your kids are gonna know that you're a
fucking good guy. So, whoa. Geez. Can we, can we, can we end on that?
I don't know. I don't think so. Hang on a second.
Yeah. Okay. My phone,
I thought she could come on. Um, she can't, she gotta do mommy duty.
I got to have a back on more man. Miss having her on here. Um,
anyways, that c a, that's the podcast for this week. Uh,
how about those dolphins? Want to know top of the AFC east, you know,
patriots one in one in second place. Um, it's still early.
Kansas City looking fucking tough. Uh, what else? Cowboys.
Defense is interested in shambles. Bright Arts.
It's called me or texts me all fucking concerned about that,
but it's still early. It's still fucking early. We'll see what's going on. My,
my beautiful daughter is crying downstairs, so I'm going to go handle that shit.
And uh, literally and figuratively, God knows
that's it. And I'll check in on you on Thursday.
A joy the Monday night football game tonight. And once again,
congratulations to the Cleveland Indians 22 in a row. I've now, you know,
obviously never saw that ever. That's in fucking incredible. That's almost,
I thought it's almost one in a month's worth of games. Yeah. Built,
there's 30 days in a month and they almost play every day. Yeah. Thank you,
Bill. All right. Go fuck yourselves. We'll talk to you on Thursday.